Eine frage die man klar mit ja
Beantworten muss ja die europäische union wird zum überwachungsstaat wenn. Im rechtsausschuss des eu-parlaments für eine reform des urheberrechts
Gestimmt wird dann werden upload filter wie content id auf youtube nämlich zum verpflichtenden
Zensur element und die cdu treibt es voran obwohl im koalitionsvertrag
Etwas ganz anderes geregelt ist ein wichtiges thema wir müssen etwas tun, herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Das heute. Ein video quasi in eigener sache eigentlich steht im koalitionsvertrag
zitat, eine verpflichtung von plattformen zum einsatz von upload filtern, um von nutzern hochgeladenen inhalten nach
Urheberrechtsverletzenden inhalte zu filtern lehnen wir als unverhältnismäßig
Ab trotzdem treibt der eu abgeordnete axel voss von der cdu genau den voran jetzt soll
darüber abgestimmt werden und weil einige
Rechtspopulistische parteien mit der cdu stimmen sieht es danach aus dass der vorschlag durchkommen. Dabei ist der vorschlag von unkenntnis
Durchdrungen und die macht es schon. Heute filtern wie dem content id system von youtube schwer
Im urheberrecht gibt es das recht auf freie benutzung das heißt ich darf, ein
Neues werk unter der benutzung eines existierenden werkes erstellen zb kann ich filmausschnitte
neu zusammenschneiden dies muss immer zur schaffung eines
Neuen werkes führen best of und so weiter das ist verboten - dagegen sind genau das und explizit erlaubt. Ein
automatischer filter dagegen kann das nicht unterscheiden
Eine wichtige grundlage der entwicklung der kultur wird torpediert und es gibt das zitatrecht
Um, thesen in videos artikeln und so weiter zu belegen dann darf ich filmausschnitte fotos und texte verwenden
Ein filter kann auch das nicht unterscheiden zudem ist ein solches allgemeines monitoring laut rechtsprechung des europäischen
Gerichtshofes verboten die befürworter argumentieren das würde ja immer einzeln nach bestimmten parteien gesucht aber das eben überall
Und allgemein so ein quatsch also das ist allgemeines monitoring zudem wird die privatsphäre verletzt und der datenschutz damit
Sich die user beschweren können müssen. Deren daten gesammelt werden geht nicht anders. Und schon. Heute funktionieren beschwerde mechanismen nicht
Weil zum beispiel youtube komplett überfordert ist zuweilen dauertest tage. Ein fälschlicherweise
gesperrt das video frei zu bekommen oder einen gelöschten kanal wieder, frei zu bekommen ich sage nur dattel täter
Und open mind
Und leider funktioniert das nur mit massiver intervention kann ich aus eigener erfahrung sagen und die normalen wege die bringen da gar nichts
und schon heute werden diese systeme missbraucht der zugriff auf content
Id hat der ist versucht kritische beiträge über sich zu löschen und genau das soll auch schon passiert sein wenn
Er beweise dafür habt schickt mir den video ling. Und am besten das skript auf rezept ich sehe mir das video
Dann, über das youtube back end an vielleicht kann ich sogar etwas tun, und ganz am rande seien
auch das leistungsschutzrecht erwähnt § 11 in deutschland gescheitert
Soll es jetzt europaweit die bezahlung von verlinkungen erzwingen teilen gehört dann der vergangenheit
An man man man alles in allem geht da was in die
komplett falsche richtung wir müssen etwas tun
Und ihr könnt ist unten in der video beschreibung habe ich die petition von
Change.org verlinkt bitte unbedingt unterschreiben es geht, um unsere freiheit auf whatsapp schicke ich
Euch eine nachricht die bitte an möglichst viele leute einfach weiterleitet. Und sie bittet sie wiederum weiterzuleiten
Tretet eine lawine los und unten in der video beschreibung habe ich noch
Einen text reinkopiert in der zukunft ist das ja nicht mehr erlaubt den. Ihr eurem oder eurer
Eu-abgeordneten mail schicken können zu whatsapp kommt. Ihr über diesen link bitte folgt mehr da und macht mit diesen. Irrsinn zu stoppen
Einfach hier draufklicken. Und am besten auch. Meinen. Schwesterkanal. Klick zum
Social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klingen aber nicht die
Dem auge noch vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür. Auch draufklicken anonymus was ist axa ja da war doch mal was
man bis das
bleibt an